sí muy buenos días pues condiciones
climáticas bastante difíciles aquí en
parís tan solo 13 grados de temperatura
algo de lluvia pero sobre todo mucho
viento ya hay varios jugadores que
durante los encuentros han pedido
incluso a los árbitros que por favor
suspenda el partido porque de verdad que
han sido unas condiciones muy difíciles
sobre todo para aquellos que no están
jugando en la cancha principal que es el
philips a pie edificio que ustedes ven a
mis espaldas y que este año está
estrenando ese techo retráctil así que
por un lado es bueno porque allí pues al
menos podrán jugar resguardados de la
lluvia de este viento y sobre todo
podrán jugar hasta altas horas de la
noche algo que puede ser bastante
probable en vista de estas condiciones
climáticas y en caso de que los partidos
en las otras canchas pues se tengan que
ser aplazados o quizás comenzar con un
poco de tiempo de retraso en el día de
hoy ya hubo un primer golpe con la vida
del belga número 11 de cabeza de serie
número 11 que ya fue eliminado esta
mañana ahora en este momento está
jugando la número 1 del mundo
cabeza de serie número uno del mundo
simona halep y bueno vamos a ver qué más
pasa en esta primera jornada de roland
garros